[Music]
hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm gonna answer question phone
on my newsletter readers Caroline who
runs a divorce coaching program and is
trying to increase her networking skills
and meet the right people to help her
grow her business
so specifically she's targeting two
groups family mediators family mediators
and lawyers so she's trying to get in
front of these two groups and so just to
start off Caroline it's great to meet
you thank you for the question and it's
really good that you know the exact type
of business you run and the exact type
of people you need to be introduced to
tubule to grow your business so a lot of
entrepreneurs haven't really made that
step yet so congrats on that in terms of
being introduced to these people you
mentioned that you're going to meet up
event and you're going to board of trade
events I try to think and see are these
people going to those events and if you
look at meetup events you know lawyers
are usually pretty busy especially
family lawyers and I don't see them a
lot at these types of events and family
mediators is a really specific type of
person and the odds of you meeting
somebody at one of these events is
probably pretty low so what I would do
instead of just hitting up events and
hoping to meet somebody I would
proactively seek these guys out so seek
them out and what I would do is do a
quick Google search try to find anybody
who is you know family lawyers or family
mediators and introduce yourself you
know try to go out there set up a coffee
meeting go for coffee introduce yourself
see if there's a way that you might be
able to help each other with your
business and you know you can also
potentially give them some business as
well and so if you position it as
learning about each other and
potentially passing business to each
other a lot of these guys would be open
to being able to do that meeting and we
want to come in and meet
because these guys they want to grow
their business as well another you not
just pitching them in this value that
you could potentially break through the
people as well then most of the time to
be willing to come and take your meeting
so I would do a Google search and it
also looked for Google News if you sign
up for Google News Alerts you could type
in certain keywords you can type in your
family mediator or family lawyer
followed by I think you said you were in
Toronto or Richmond Hill put those
keywords in and anytime somebody's
mentioned in the news and that their
family mediator or family lawyer you'll
get an email and that's a great way to
be able to quickly introduce yourself to
say hey I saw that you were featured in
the Toronto Star Congrats in a great
article I had this great coaching
program and I think you know we might be
able to help each other I would love to
take you out for coffee and introduce
myself and learn a little bit more about
your business as well suddenly my first
approach go out and target them I think
you'd have a much better success rate
than just going to meet up events a
board of trade events and hoping that
your ideal connector is there if you're
finding that it's really hard to get in
front of these people and they're saying
no and they're too busy and they don't
want to just network with you the next
thing you can do is try to interview
them so interview them and where you can
do is put together a guide of advice
from the top family lawyers in Toronto
and you can say I'm creating this guy
then gonna be promoting up the top
family lawyers in Toronto and their
advice and I'd love to interview you
they'll take half an hour and get your
tips and opinions on what's happening
with family law and you know why
somebody should sign up and buy from you
so there you're offering a lot of value
to somebody and you actually have to go
through and you know create this
publication but it could just be an
online ebook that you promote from your
website and people are generally
flattered by it and they want the
exposure and publicity and attention so
it's a lot easier to get that meeting
and of course then they become curious
about what you're doing and how you're
gonna promote it and what your business
is all about so it's a great way to get
that introduction when I had one of my
first software companies we were trying
to sell into salespeople insurance
brokers for financial advisors and at
the time we weren't a known quantity and
you know we were young entrepreneurs so
we did was we partnered up with a whole
bunch of highly famous and successful
writers like Zig Ziglar and Tom Peters
and we created a guide to professional
success and we email all of them and
said we'd love to interview you or take
one of your articles but professional
success and put it together in a guide
and I also wrote my own article too and
I contributed to it so now I'm an author
with all these great authors and we
publish it and release it on on our
website and that was a great way to get
that first introduction to a lot of
these expert authors who otherwise
wouldn't have paid any attention to us
and we were just a startup company
nobody really knew who we were but they
all said yes so that could be a great
way to introduce yourself to some of
these companies if you're finding that
they don't want to meet with you for
coffee to discuss each other's
businesses so that's what I would do I
think you'd have a much better hit rate
I think people would be open to meeting
with you and if enough people learn
about what you're doing then when they
see that their clients have a need then
they're much more likely to to refer
them to you because they know you they
like you they've met you they like what
your business is all about they see that
you're a friendly person and they think
you can help their clients so hopefully
that helps Caroline if you guys like the
video please give it a thumbs up below
and it also love to hear oh you have to
think if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for next
episode
[Music]
you
[Music]